the controversy in the adult film
industry made me headed to the ballot
box and the fight could cost taxpayers
millions AIDS activists have gone to
court to force Los Angeles County health
officials to require adult film actors
to use condoms or shut down movie sets
that don't comply self regulation has
failed miserably becomes too
the porn industry this isn't the
government's place this isn't the
government's place in the beginning of
2012 Mayor Antonio via Carosa signed an
ordinance requiring condoms for all
adult films shot in the city of Los
Angeles in the five years we've been
fighting this battle we've come a long
long way Michael Weinstein is the
president of the AIDS Healthcare
Foundation which is responsible for
pushing the initiative now it's been
clearly established that it is against
the law to make these films without a
condom we've passed an initiative in the
city of Los Angeles and we're headed to
the ballot in November
although the city ordinance has not been
enforced the county will be voting on a
similar ordinance that includes
expensive and controversial enforcement
practices over the last five years there
have been over 300,000 adult scene shot
Steven Hirsch is the founder and
co-chairman of one of the largest porn
production companies in the country well
there's several reasons that the
industry is against condoms one is that
it's just not needed the testing
procedures that are in place work and
work well the performers are comfortable
with the testing procedures and the
companies are comfortable with the
testing procedures second reason is
movies with condoms simply don't sell as
well people don't want to watch movies
with condoms when you watch an adult
movie it's more of a fantasy and they
don't care to see what happens in real
life and the third reason is this would
only pertain to people in LA County who
are producing in LA County movies are
produced all over the country
so it wouldn't be fair to take one group
of producers and make them follow one
law while the rest of the producers
don't have to the gay industry has been
overwhelmingly condom and people haven't
stopped buying the product and what's
the acceptable number of infections that
people should have to be subjected to
when they go to work
there's absolutely no acceptable level
of transmittable disease we just go on
our on the history I don't approve to
cut a lot off I think that you know if
you would like to use condoms that's
your choice but I don't think that it's
something that should be mandatory Aleks
chance is one of a growing number of
porn stars coming out against the forced
use of condoms in porn the industry as
it stands right now I see testing is the
best measure we go there we get tested
every month every 14 to 30 days some
companies require 14 day tests some
require 28 some require 30 it's up to
each individual company on my wish it
was more standardized with that but with
the industry shutdowns like they are I
think that is the best response testing
is not prevention its screening to find
disease it doesn't prevent diseases from
being transmitted you can take a test
today and you can be infected tomorrow
and you can work in a film the next day
we are trying to promote condom use we
are concerned about performers and we
care for performance in our health care
centers free of charge but we are also
concerned about the message that's being
sent by unsafe sex if this passes a
couple of things may happen people may
leave the state take the jobs with them
and off they'll go to other states to
produce the second thing is they may go
underground and not only will they not
use condoms they won't get tested either
because now they're totally going under
them and that could turn into be a huge
problem I'm not going to speculate on a
negative unintended consequences they
sell their products to hotels they sell
them to cable TV they cannot go
underground it Larry Flynt has a
skyscraper on the corner of La Cienega
and Wilshire that is not going run
aground there are only two states in the
Union where an adult film is not
considered illegal prostitution that's
California and New Hampshire you know it
gets awfully cold taking off your
clothes and New Hampshire in the winter
I don't think the industry is moving
there I think people tend to look out
for their budgets first so if the
company thinks that they're not going to
make as much money shooting in Los
Angeles because of this condom law and
all the extras
he's associated with it then I think
they'll move I think people care more
about their bottom line than any
building at the end of most movies it
says no animal was hurt in the making of
this film okay so we do more to protect
a dog in a movie than we do a human
being in adult films there is something
called being reasonable and being
reasonable says that we're in the sex
business there is a chance that somebody
could contract a sexually transmitted
disease the key is how is an industry do
we react to that and do we react well
and do we react quickly look at the
examples that we've set and make your
own decision we're not telling them what
the content of their movie should be
we're telling them that the actors
should be protected in those films that
may offend the Rotarians but that's how
our society works this isn't the
government's place this isn't the
government's place and in a time where
we have a huge budget deficit they're
going to take their time and energy to
figure out how to place an industry that
does a fine job of policing itself
[Music]
you